peut-on allumer une ampoule avec du
fromage la commune d'albertville a
relevé le défi et tenez vous bien à elle
a été capable d'alimenter plus de 1000
habitants à l'énergie fromagère ça s'est
fait dans cette usine de fabrication de
beaufort qui a pu extraire le lactosérum
afin de produire du biogaz et cela est
juste une des utilisations possibles du
fromage car oui cet aliment cache de
nombreux mystères
si secret auquel nous allons répondre la
fascinante science du fromage pourquoi
les fromages ont-ils des goûts
différents
vous voyez tous ces fromages ils ont des
goûts différents on est d'accord
pourtant ils ont tous la même base du
lait tous les fromages qui naissent
ressemble à ça alors qu'est ce qui
explique qu'on est arrivé à plus de 1000
variétés de fromages en france eh bien
il existe trois critères principaux
d'abord un la couleur elle n'a rien de
naturel c'est une pure invention
marketing
les premiers à avoir ajouté une couleur
à leurs fromages et le raid leicester
une sorte de cheddar sauf que le cheddar
de base c'est pas orange c'est blanc
c'est pour se démarquer de la
concurrence qu'on a ajouté le colorant
e160 b le nom fait peur mais c'est en
fait que du rock ou un pigment naturel
qui vient d'un arbuste d'amérique
tropicale
il sert aussi à protéger des moisissures
tout au long de l'affinage et certains
même l'utilisent comme antioxydant un
véritable nettoyant intestinale mais du
coup les fromages aune là aussi il ya du
colorant et bien dans ce cas c'est
naturel quand une vache mangent de
l'herbe
elle consomme de la bêta carotène ce
qu'il y a dans les carottes mais aussi
dans le gazon voulons retrouver ensuite
dans le lait ce qui est l'explication de
la couleur jaune du beurre une exception
quand même le fromage de chèvre sera
toujours blanc parce que la bêta
carotène et transformé en vitamine a
dans le corps de la chèvre ensuite de la
croûte des durs des molles des
comestibles et dégueulasse encore une
fois il y a une grande diversité
la raison c'est ce qu'on ajoute au
fromage en cours d'affinage une croûte
de blanche comme le camembert c'est
grâce au sport vaporiser sur le fromage
nos croûte orangée ou rougeâtres et déjà
plus industrielles on lave le fromage
avec de la saumure et de l'alcool ce qui
favorise les moisissures rouge
enfin trois c'est le plus important le
goût sachez que les maîtres fromagers
ont inventé une roue qui permet de
décrire précisément chacun des goûts
existants plus de 70 saveurs recensés à
ce jour
mais comment avec du simple mais peut-il
y avoir autant de différences selon les
scientifiques plus de 20% des arômes
proviennent des aliments que les animaux
mangent mais les 80% restants c'est ce
qu'on y ajoute la recette de la sinne
heures un camembert - brille par exemple
sir leur saveur de la penicillium kaman
darty qui est ajouté au début de la
fabrication
alors qu à roquefort tient sa forte
saveur d'une moisissure tout
particulièrement du pénis ilium
roquefort- ti et oui le goût du fromage
et en tête celui des champignons qu'ils
ont colonisé plein mais bon ça va ça ne
compte pas dans des 5 fruits et légumes
par jour faut pas déconner quand même
pourquoi certains pros maj on t'il des
troncs c'est la façon iconique de
représenter le fromage pourtant il y en
a qu'un seul avec des trous les mentale
suisse oui mais non vous allez me dire
que le gruyère aussi a des trous et bien
en fait non cette erreur vient du fait
que les mentale été distribués sous le
nom de gruyère en france et depuis basse
est resté voilà à quoi ressemble un vrai
gruyère jusqu'en 1917
on ne savait pas pourquoi il y avait des
trous dans les mental la théorie d'un
certain william clark c'est que les
trous se former sous l'action de dioxyde
de carbone produit par des bactéries
qu'ils connaissaient pas sauf qu'on a
remarqué un truc plus on à
industrialiser la fabrication - il y
avait deux trous les mentale allait-il
disparaître de l'histoire sans qu'on
puisse percer son secret ce n'est que
récemment qu'on a résolu l'énigme
en réalité les trous sont causés par des
gaz produits par des microparticules de
foin qui se lisent dans le lait pendant
la traite et mentale n'ait des impuretés
merci à ces femmes suisses d'avoir eu la
main sale car sans elle nous n'aurions
jamais eu ce dicton plein de profondeur
plus il ya de fromage puis il ya de
trous puis il ya de trous moins il ya de
fromage donc plus il ya de fromage - il
ya trop mal pourquoi il ya des fromages
qui puent mais qui ont bon goût
il existe de nombreux fromages qui sont
considérés comme les plus puant du monde
parmi eux le vieux boulogne un fromage
qui a été désignée en 2004 comme le
fromage le plus haut daury ferrand du
monde lors de son vieillissement la
croûte du fromage est régulièrement
laver avec de la bière pendant plusieurs
semaines un autre hommage à un procédé
similaire l'époisses de bourgogne eux
s'est lavé avec du vin blanc
dites-vous qu'il a été si puissant qu'il
a été interdit des transports en commun
en france
ici la colle va permettre la
multiplication de la bactérie pris vie
bacterial l'hymen ce qui libère un
véritable cocktail de gaz comparable à
tes chaussettes mais anti fois plus fort
alors pourquoi ont-ils bon goût quand
les mange et bien c'est parce que votre
cerveau vous piège c'est ce que va a
expliqué le scientifique james hong kong
dans une vidéo
il a révélé que lorsque l'on mange un
fromage différents composés aromatiques
sont libérés dans notre bouche ces mêmes
composés vont flotter à l'arrière de
votre nez puis être détecté mais ce qui
est bizarre c'est que l'odeur n'est pas
la même
avant et après que vous le manger c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'odeur à l'envers au
lieu de sentir la mauvaise odeur du
fromage votre cerveau va la combiner
avec le crémeux que vous avez sur votre
langue magie après la première bouchée
le fromage sent bon le fromage peut être
dangereux et toxiques
tout à l'heure je vous ai parlé de
fromage puant mais savez vous que
certains fromages pourrez vous tuer il
existe un fromage considéré comme l'un
des plus dangereux qui est même
interdite dans l'union européenne pour
des raisons sanitaires
le kazoo mars où les éleveurs laisse
pourrir un fromage appelé pecorino pour
que les mouches puisse y pondre leurs
oeufs
une fois les eaux est clos les larves
vont se nourrir du fromage et le
transformer en cette crème ignoble de
trucs dangereux c'est que déjà en terme
d'hygiène baas est pas fou mais surtout
les larves
elles sont balèzes sa mère avec le
fromage elles sont devenus totalement
résistantes à l'acide et donc aussi à
celui de votre estomac
elle peut donc y survivre et percé vos
intestins en mode topic heures même si
heureusement aucun n'a été recensé
jusqu'à présent ce n'est pas le seul
danger posé par le fromage par exemple
une idée reçue présent depuis plusieurs
années et que manger du fromage avant de
dormir provoque chez certains des
cauchemars et rêve lucide ce à cause de
la tripe tamines présents en grandes
quantités dans l'aliment qui est
précurseur à des hallucinogènes
si vous mangez du style tonnes vous
pourriez être amené à voir des
crocodiles végétariens ou encore des
chatons soldats ue
une étude a quand même été menés sur 200
patients pour vérifier ça et aucun signe
de cauchemar cette même trip tamines
agit sur le cerveau comme la cocaïne en
plus la dégradation de la cazine
produits de l'akazu morphine qui est
cette fois si proche de l'héroïne
avec tout ça on a une suggestion que le
fromage pouvait être à la base d'
addiction
et bien c'est presque vrai une étude sur
500 patients a montré des comportements
addictogène quand vous écrivez j'aime le
fromage ou poser fièrement à côté de
votre athlète vous n'êtes pas mieux
qu'un mec qui a un t-shirt bob marley et
qui vous dit well agoria bleus est
tellement meilleur
après l'étude montre aussi que notre
propre corse avait limité les
comportements autodestructeurs
étant donné qu'au bout de milliers
d'années s'est inscrit dans nos gènes
résistance un dernier facteur de risque
c'est qu'à la base le lait c'est une
boisson pour faire grandir les vaches pb
ce n'est pas vraiment pour les humains
adultes qui puisait bah oui c'est plein
d'hormones et de booster de croissance
sur l'humain quelques études sont
prouvés que ça pourrait être corrélé à
l'augmentation des maladies cardiaques
et au cancer de la prostate et du col de
l'utérus
après c'est comme tout éviter les abus
manger équilibré et le fromage ne vous
posera aucun problème
pourquoi certaines personnes détestent
le fromage je n'aime pas le fromage
c'est pas un problème de goût le
parmesan en poudre sur la pizza c'est
délicieux c'est juste que la simple idée
de sentir ou manger cette chose ou
aurait pu nuire
je ne connaîtrai jamais le goût du
camembert j'ai même failli ne jamais
connaître celui de la pizza puisque
jusqu'à mes 21 ans jean lever la
garniture sur celle-ci par dégoût de la
mozzarella
c'est en découvrant que ça n'avait pas
debout que j'ai réussi à l'apprécier
c'est assez handicapant enfonce puisque
mes amis se vexe quand je décline une
invitation à les manger une raclette
l'horreur comme 6% des français je suis
atteint de tir aux phobies
j'ai peur du fromage pour comprendre le
pourquoi du comment 300 personnes ont
été invitées à sentir du fromage toute
la journée
le but était de savoir ce qui se passe
dans le cerveau des personnes qui
n'aiment pas ça les irm ont montré
qu'une des hommes qui s'activent quand
on a faim ne l'est pas chez ceux qui
sont tir au phoque la zone du cerveau
attribués aux mécanismes de récompenses
activer une sensation de dégoût
c'est donc naturel de détester le
fromage c'est juste de côté en minorité
aussi certaines personnes ne mangent pas
à cause d'une intolérance au lactose
les personnes qui ont ce problème ont du
mal à le digérer par manque de lactase
une enzyme permettant de transformer le
lactose en glucose et galactose une
substance plus facilement bio
assimilable par le corps il faut savoir
que dans le monde il ya probablement
plus de personnes intolérantes que
tolérante
c'est un luxe qu'on a en europe mais
dans certaines régions du monde
une grande partie de la population peut
simplement pas en manger alors j'ai pas
trouvé d'études clair mais il semblerait
que pour les intolérants au lactose
certains fromages c'est possible puisque
avec la fermentation bactérienne les
lactose serait transformé en acide
lactique pourtant proche dit ça mais
j'en veux toujours pas laissez moi vous
donner le coup de grâce
vous êtes nombreux à être allergique aux
acariens et peut-être avez-vous eu des
réactions bizarres en mangeant du
fromage c'est normal parce que la
carrière est un ingrédient du fromage
c'est les sirops et artisans on en
asperge sur le fromage afin qu'ils se
développent dans la croûte perçant des
trous microscopiques qui laisse le
fromage respirer manger la croûte de la
mimolette de la tomme de savoie du viol
et du cantal
c'est vers le plein de bonnes protéines
alors oui la prochaine fois que vous me
jugerez parce que je ne fais pas de
raclette avec vous pas grave je vous les
laisse se les cailler pour y investit de
bactéries moisissures et acariens qu'on
surnomme si joliment fromage et bon
appétit bien sûr le futur du fromage à
travers le temps de nombreuses méthodes
de fabrication du fromage ont vu le jour
la plus récente ce sont les bio hackers
qui ont eu l'idée
de fabriquer du fromage 100% végétalien
pas du faux fromages nom du vrai fromage
mais sans utiliser du lait animal
leur idée est simple produire la caséine
la protéine du lait à partir d'une
mesure génétiquement modifiés qu'il
suffit juste ensuite de mélanger la
casino autre ingrédient du lait genre de
l'eau le sucre le gras et bam
un vrai laisse 100% vegan ils ont lancé
sur un financement participatif et ont
récolté plus de 30000 euros et on verra
ce que ça goûte des fromages loufoque
il y en a d'autres par exemple les deux
plus cher du monde du fromage des lan ou
du fromage d'ânesse si c'est si cher
c'est que ce sont des animaux qui
produisent très peu de lait et surtout
allait vraiment pas facile a transformé
en fromage
résultat ils peuvent atteindre 1000
euros le kilo dans le loufoque on peut
aller encore plus loin
un étudiant du nom de myriam seaman a eu
la prodigieuse idée de produire du
fromage à base de lait humain
elle avait demandé à plusieurs femmes
qui a allaité de donner leur lait pour
produire touche fromage son objectif
était de montrer les utilisations
possibles des sécrétions humaines et ce
n'est pas la seule à l'avoir fait le
chef d'un restaurant new yorkais en a
même fait à partir du lait maternel de
son épouse et puisqu'on est au fond du
trou dans le fromage
il y à des bactéries n'est ce pas eh
bien des chercheurs ont essayé de
fabriquer du fromage à partir de celles
provenant du trou de ton nombril ou
encore de tsl les bactéries de ton corps
sont similaires à ceux utilisés pour
faire du fromage à eux de conclure que
le fromage obtenir à la même odeur que
la zone du corps prélevés miam miam
délicieux et tiens puisqu'on est dans
les mauvaises idées
le fromage du futur fait tant au goût du
coca cola ou de la pastèque ma main à
couper que ça existera parce que vous
êtes tous en train de saboter le fromage
ah ah merci à auray le russe pour cette
vidéo merci aux monteurs d'être toujours
présent ça fait un an que l' aventure
science trash a commencé on vous dis à
très bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos
sur vous
[Musique]